hey guys enjoy this brilliant interview
with professor stephen hicks
we had a few issues with his video the
internet connection wasn't great
but it is literally one of the very best
interviews we have ever done
so stick with it you're gonna enjoy it
you're gonna absolutely love it the
audio quality
is perfect the video isn't great but
don't worry
it is worth it stick with it enjoy
hello and welcome to trigonometry
i'm francis foster i'm constantine
kitchen and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
and it does not get better than the
guest we have for you today he's a
philosopher and author
professor stephen hicks welcome to
trigonometry hey thanks francis and
constantine honored to be with you
it is a great pleasure to to have you
here with us uh
i have so many questions for you francis
has a ton as well but i thought we'd
start actually by telling you a little
bit about
our journey which is we're two comedians
and about three years ago we started to
feel something in the water there was
something going on where
uh we you know francis is an old-school
lefty i'm so some somewhere in the
center with a few classically liberal
views
and we started to notice that the
overton window for
things you could joke about was
shrinking suddenly the idea that
comedians are supposed to challenge the
mainstream narrative was no longer
no longer true somehow you would you
would be punished you would be
criticized for making jokes about things
identity became a huge part of our world
and we started trigonometry
to talk to people to try and understand
what has happened
and what is happening uh can you explain
to us
what what what's been happening and why
we've spent three years of our lives
dealing with this
what has been the transformation that
has happened in our societies in the
west
i think there are a couple of human
constants at work one is
uh you guys are comedians and all of us
should have a sense of humor but we do
know
that there are lots of people who have
absolutely no sense of humor
whatever is going on in their life
they take it seriously they uh they
can't joke about it they don't
like jokes about that and as you know
humor
in several of its main forms is
subversive and so they feel it as an
attack
and they want to to shut it down so the
connection to the overton window is uh
is precisely good
from a comedian perspective everything
there should be no window
anything is fair game but the shrinking
of the overton window is an indication
of uh
context in which some things are just
not allowed to be
said we do know people have a very
narrow
overton window some of them the second
thing is
that whenever a group of people gets
into
positions of power in whatever
institution they're talking about it can
be a family it can be a business it can
be a college or a university
uh there's a philosophical commitment
they they make are they
interested in each person as an
individual that person being
cultivated to add their talents to
develop their talents
or are they an authoritarian that they
have their
vision and they want to impose it upon
anyone
using whatever tools are are at their
disposal
and certainly in uh higher education
this is a prime
area where this happens because then you
have teachers with students
and there's a big power differential so
the philosophical commitment of the
the teacher comes comes out very quickly
so there is a constant there about the
choice that we all make about what
kind of person we're going to be in
interacting with other individuals who
we know are going to have
different views different tastes
different values and so on
on in life it's either going to be a
mutual respecting
and perhaps ultimately tolerating go our
own way if we can't
agree atmosphere or one person is going
to try to do a power play and
and and dominate now what often happens
though in these institutions is you have
a plurality of
positions available and so whether the
authoritarian type
likes it or not they have to put up with
dissenting views alternative views there
being vigorous debate and so on
but when uh the the plurality stops
being a plurality and you have
one position uh with a large number of
people
who are in position to dominate then any
pretenses about
civil discourse and debate and overturn
windows and so on goes out the window
and people start to use authoritarian
methods in a social context so
that's what's been happening in in
universities now
you guys are comedians you know i've
noticed the examples at my own
university as well we always had two or
three
comedians who would come through each
year and uh and give a routine for the
for the students
and you could see the uh uh the shift
the kinds of comedians who were being
brought in started to be funny within a
narrower range
uh certain kinds of comedians uh just
stopped getting invited
and some of them started to become
controversial in the sense that oh
should we really be talking about that
sort of thing so
it's uh it's not just you guys it's uh
it's also over here but probably you
already know that
now those are the those are the
constants why that has happened why
there has been this shift just in the
last 10 or 15 years
there's a longer story that would have
to be have to be told because
these philosophical shifts and the
changes in demographics to one
viewpoint becoming dominant and able to
enforce itself or at least thinking that
it's able to enforce itself
those things develop slowly stephen tell
us more about that longer story before
francis takes over he has
loads of questions for as well what has
been the philosophical because i feel
like there's a philosophical shift
that underpins a cultural shift that
underpins a political shift
and now everything is political comedy
included and we experience this in our
industry
so tell us more about all of that how
has that happened
right so probably the best word here to
use is
liberal in its generic sense so
we talk about liberal democracy or
liberal societies
in which we're trying to maximize the
amount of freedom that individuals have
and then we think of education and
schooling
and raising children as preparing them
for living a certain kind of life as
free
self-responsible competent individuals
who can who can take on the world
so there is the concept of liberal
education
which has a close cognate uh uh an
underclose application
there so the question then was going is
going to be what is
education about and since human beings
are
a smart species we have a we have a big
brain
right instead of education and schooling
being a matter of a couple of weeks or a
couple of months as it is with
other animal species and we typically
spend
12 15 16 years
preparing young people for adult life
and it's not until say they're 18
that they are ready to go so what are we
doing with that
16 to 18 years and there's a certain
amount of course physical health
development and so forth
but the vast majority of it is is
cognitive
and one aspect of that cognitive
development is not only self-regulation
but social regulation how am i going to
interact with other people
what are the mores going to be what are
the explicit rules going to be
uh are we going to teach students that
uh that they need to be able to enter
into that process say in a liberal
democracy
and uh have their own ideas for how
things should be done
be willing to listen to other people's
ideas have arguments but hopefully
productive arguments
being willing to trial and error do
experiments
and so on and that whole uh
ethos requires a cognitive development
and the cultivation of a certain set of
set of principles
now what underlies that is and why
liberal education and liberal
democracies are characteristic of the
modern world
is that the modern world uh embodied
a brand new philosophical set of
commitments
uh three four five hundred years ago
where you where you put those
with those dates and all of that
what we call modernity has come under
attack from a different philosophical
perspective
that wants to basically blow up or
replace the entire modern
modern project was something something
else so if you think for example about
uh liberal democracy what are the
assumptions there well the assumption
there is
that we are individuals uh that we are
self-responsible
that we can think about very important
political cultural
matters uh that everybody should have a
voice they should be free to put their
ideas
out there even to offer themselves as
candidates
everybody should have a vote and the way
we're going to decide
very important matters is by counting up
the votes
and uh and doing what the majority of
people say
and that then is to say we have
confidence that the vast majority of
people
have the intellectual capacity to do all
of these things
and they also have the moral capacity
that they're going to respect
other people's having their own ideas
and debating
and if i happen to lose a given election
i can expect to lose the elections
frequently i'm going to go along
peacefully
and uh then re-enter the debate on the
next round and hopefully it will be uh
be a self-correcting process
so that's a that's a long way event of
saying that we respect
people in the modern world as
individuals we think they have their own
mind
and they should be free to accept it and
so a certain amount of diversity
and tolerance becomes very important
think also about how we do religion in
the modern world
and again the uh we go back to say the
1500s and we tell the story about the
reformation
encounter reformation but what came out
of that was a
a new ethos about religion again that
we're all
individuals we should be free to think
and practice or not at all practice
religion in totally our own way that we
should get the state and government out
of religion because the state
is an institute of coercion and religion
should be something that people freely
adopt or freely
reject and we need to respect and
tolerate all of them so that then is to
say
on this very important set of issues we
think it's up to people to work it out
for themselves
and we're going to give people a lot of
individual freedom
to do so uh so again we're back to
individualism and freedom
that people being rational able to to
govern their own lives
now all of that uh has implications for
science if we are
rational beings it has implications for
uh how we treat women and members of
other
uh races because they are human beings
who have their own minds and their own
values they're also
individuals who are rational so the
whole modern world has been
extraordinarily revolutionary
in all of these dimensions political
economic
scientific religious in the treatment of
other races and uh
and so on now what the postmoderns are
doing and this is for
for deep philosophical reasons is and
they're all very smart people
in the first generation people like
michelle foucault
and jacques derrida and richard rorty
and so on
is they're first-rate educated people
all of them are phds all of them in
in philosophy my field and they have
this
big perspective on what has happened in
the grand sweep
of historical development in philosophy
in culture and politics
and so on and all of them are convinced
that the modern
project is a failure and it's a failure
intellectually and they believe also
that it's a failure
culturally that it is it's based on
individualism
but we are not individuals it's based on
the idea that we have rationality
that we are rational animals and they
don't believe fundamentally in
rationality
anymore and then as a result of that
they're not going to believe
in liberal education it's going to be a
different kind of education that they
are interested in
and fundamentally they're not going to
believe in any sort of liberal democracy
and so
the political manifestations are going
to be very different
as well and stephen what you're talking
about
is really really really fascinating one
thing that i want to touch on
is you've mentioned authoritarianism now
to me
it seems these types of people
that we that we're discussing about they
very much want to reintroduce
authoritarianism if you look at the
the example that you used about
comedians well
i don't like this particular comedian
therefore we shut them down
therefore we don't listen to them i
don't like this type of thought i don't
like these arguments therefore i shut
them down
isn't this just a rather grandiose way
of reintroducing authoritarianism
back into our society that's exactly
right that that is the political
manifestation now authoritarianism
means uh a certain kind of social power
or political power
right that rather than listening to you
and letting you speak
and perhaps entering in into an argument
with you which has its own
ethos instead i try literally
to have you physically removed
and if you start to speak then i try
physically
to intimidate you or to overthrow you so
authoritarianism is about the use of
physical power
and of course uh political dictators
whom we call authoritarians that's
exactly
what what we do so yeah and this is the
deep question am i going to treat you
as a free agent and have to respect that
and perhaps tolerate that
or am i going to try to threaten you and
physically shut you down and that latter
is the authoritarian move
now the thing that's different about the
modern authoritarians is
well authoritarianism historically has
always come
in in in two forms i mean one kind of
authoritarianism
is a kind of uh i would call it a
pretense
objectivity kind of authoritarianism
that i think
that i am a special individual that you
know maybe i have been
endowed by god with special moral
character or special
insight and because i have this object
definitely one of them yeah i was going
to say that
yeah so because i have this objective
source
that is granting me and authorizing
me to use power over you lesser beings
then i am morally justified in using
power to stop you from saying the stupid
immoral things that you otherwise might
say now that of course can uh
can come in religious form it can come
in secular forms as well
uh what's different about the
post-moderns though
is that in addition to being against the
modern world
they're also against uh what we
typically call the pre-modern world
where that
kind of religiously based right or or or
or
you know if i'm the king and i acquired
power on the battlefield or through
political machinations
that demonstrates my superiority and
gives me
the the right to use my power to shut
other people down
they also believe that those are are the
veneers of objectivity
are also faulty so what they're left
with is a deep belief that
everybody is is in a subjective
perspective
we don't get our values from god we
don't get our values from
from from nature we don't get them from
our from our own
biological needs instead all values
are just uh subjective we make them up
or they are conditioned into us by
random social forces so nobody really
knows what's true
nobody's in a better position of knowing
anything more there is no such thing
really as
truth or knowledge everyone's values are
just a subjective
uh set of emotional commitments that
they have
so the postmoderns will say you know i
might try to have a
veneer of saying oh no really my values
came from god and yours didn't
but that's just a veneer so they they
will not buy into any of that so all we
are left with is
different people have different belief
systems different value commitments
and uh we can't reason about them we
can't find out which ones are better
which ones are worse because all of
that's just as subjective as well
so really all we are left with is a
social power struggle
and you might as well just jump into
that power struggle
and use any strategies or any tactics
you can
to have your subjective value
commitments prevail
so it's an authoritarianism but based on
an explicit
subjectivity but it also seems to me
stephen that it's an authoritarianism
mixed with i don't know the word for it
but
you with a desire for a utopia which
which has never existed and they believe
that if they
or thought uh assert themselves in this
authoritarian manner
they will achieve nirvana utopia where
everybody's equal
as long as we do these particular steps
and you shut up and you don't and you're
not allowed to speak
yeah well i think there's a split then
within uh within post-modernism
uh on that issue and that's that's
nicely said what you've said there i
think some of the some of the
post-moderns don't believe in
utopia at all uh
because what what would utopia be utopia
would be the idea
that there is an ideal reality
that is proper for human beings and it
should be the same for all human beings
and i have genuine knowledge about how
to get human beings from where we are
now to that utopia
if you start to go down that road then
you are
not a postmodernist in the sense of a
subjectivist right or a
uh or a relativist you have become an
objectivist
small o and a universalist again and
you're starting to sound more like an
old-fashioned
authoritarian but i think you're right
that there is a there is a generational
shift and when we use very broad labels
like
modern pre-modern postmodern and so on
uh they are at a very high level of
abstraction so the
a standard analogy is to say you know
someone can be religious and there's a
big difference between people who are
committed to being
religious and those who are naturalistic
purely in their thinking
but religion is a very broad label and
as we know
religion then divides into many major
religions and each of those major
religions has lots of subspecies
and not all of the members of all of
those subspecies even though they will
share some general traits
will agree on everything and they will
disagree on some pretty fundamental
things you know we know there are some
religious people who believe in heaven
and happy ever after for everyone
some people who believe in religion but
they think that most people are going to
go to hell and only an elect few are
going to go
other people who believe in religion but
they don't really focus so much on
heaven and hell they focus
on uh just living a moral life in the
here and now and so on so i think
your your utopian version of
post-modernism
uh in my taxonomy it's a second
generation
uh uh of aspect those who will
commit to the idea of post-modernism
that we're not individuals
we're members of groups and that these
groups subjectively construct our
values but what these ones do is they
convince themselves in some way that
their group's values
really are best for all human beings
and those other human beings if only
they were reshaped
appropriately they could come to adopt
my group's values and the world would be
a better place whether it would be
utopia or not
i don't know so um
there are different political versions
of post-modernism as well
the historical point is that
post-modernism first developed out of
the left
out of the far left now the left also is
a big tent with many
uh subgroups as well but there was a
subsection of the far
left and that left did have a certain
set of values that it used to believe
were universalistic values to be imposed
on everyone in
in society and a certain kind of making
everybody equal across all social
dimensions was part of that
far leftist package so one of the ways
of getting to your
utopian understanding or at least of the
utopian types is to say
that they've retained that certain kind
of very robust egalitarianism everything
must be made equal
and that's combined with a certain
number of post-modern themes
so we have a kind of hybrid cultural
movement
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be cancel culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
that's really interesting and stephen i
want to ask you about
a thing again coming back to the the
comedy side of things
and it's it's broader than comedy of
course but there has been in recent
years
the spread of the proliferation i would
say of the idea that
words are violence the words cause harm
where does that come from because that's
such a revolutionary concept if we think
back to even five years ago
in our political field or in comedy that
did not exist as far as i remember i
don't remember anyone telling me a
university
words of violence and yet here we are 15
years later
and now that is like the motif to our
whole conversation about everything
where did that come from ah
well again there's a two long stories
that need to be told here that come
together one comes from
linguistics and from more broadly
speaking epistemology
and the other one comes from your
understanding of human natures and
human cognitive capacities in general do
you think of individuals as individuals
or
or collectivities so let me start with
that start with the latter one
so if you take the debate between
individualism and
collectivism uh so then we asked the
question you know am i
an individual who has control of his own
mind and so i shape
my own character i choose my own values
i develop my habits and i accomplish
something in my life as a as an
individual
or do i understand myself as more
like a lump of plasticine that has been
born into the world but i was born into
a certain social context
and all of these external forces shaped
and manipulated and developed me into
the kind of being that i
i am so physically i might seem like a
unique individual but really i'm just a
vehicle through which
all of these social forces are are
developing
in in me so hold that in mind
uh if you are going to believe on the on
the positive side that words are a form
of
speech uh the traditional view that is
now being attacked and what we typically
say is
well i as an individual i can take the
word
i can think about it for myself what it
connects to in reality
or if i don't think it actually connects
to anything in reality
and that when i choose to use a word i
am
choosing a specific meaning and i'm
trying to communicate to you
as a particular individual and i if
communication is going to work then i
really have to listen to you to
see where you are as a unique individual
or coming from
and so explain myself right and so forth
so all of that individualistic
understanding
uh uh presupposes that individuals
are the operative cognitive units
now if you shift to seeing individuals
as
vehicles through which social forces are
acting
that changes everything including your
understanding of how
language works so the assumption here is
going to be
that languages already exist
before you come into existence and now
these are all the controversial things
but i'll just put them out there
right that uh uh the meanings of
language are all
socially constructed they are not a
matter of individuals
in cognitive relationship to to the
world
instead we absorb a language from our
social group
that shapes our mind and languages
again i don't agree with this but i'm
just putting this out there come with a
certain
grammar and that grammar builds in
certain metaphysical assumptions about
the way the world
works in its syntax and so different
language groups then have different
philosophies built into their languages
so
the end result of this then is going to
be if you follow this linguistic route
that you have different social groups
each of which has a different language
but that language has been conditioned
into them to think about the world
in very different ways what that that
means is that there's not really any way
for
people of different language groups to
communicate with each other
right and that means that we can't have
rational individuals engaging in
conversation with each other
and they both have a common reference in
reality to check what their words mean
so ultimately with some work they can
come to agreement instead you're just
left with these
different social groups and their
languages are evolving in different
directions
their thinking is evolving in different
directions so any disagreement between
those social groups
is uh unresolvable in principle
well this is what i was going to ask you
about so basically to put what you're
saying into simple language
if human beings are infinitely malleable
and if
language is the method by which uh
those those people are changed then when
i'm on stage
performing a comedy show i'm not
actually trying to communicate something
for the purposes of making you laugh
what i'm really doing is trying to use
the power of the microphone and words
to shape you to take a certain world
view and if that world view
is wrong or bad or evil i am causing
literal harm to to millions of people
around the world but
the more troubling thing about your
analysis essentially what you're saying
and correct me if i'm wrong but what i'm
hearing is this world view
if applied to society inevitably leads
to irresolvable conflict because exactly
along group lines and so that's why
what you've found in the last 10 years
especially is
uh when you go up on stage they don't
see francis they don't see constantine
as an individual
who's expressing his own ideas and his
quirky sense of humor whatever that
is they will see you as a male
they will see you as a white guy they
will see you as
i don't know what your sexualities are
but immediately
you stop being seen as an individual and
you just see
you seem to see come to be seen as a
member of a group
and everything that uh those groups do
uh is flowing through you and if i'm a
member of a different group then
immediately we are in an adversarial
circumstance
and i treat it as an adversarial
circumstance now another
aspect of this becomes more uh more
directly psychological on the words as
violence theme is that everybody
recognizes that words can have a harm
right and violence is a certain kind of
harm
but there's been the standard thing to
say there's a
the distinction between physical harms
and psychological harms
and so if i you know if i take a stick
and i start beating
your body right with a stick well that
is a
physical harm but also your body you
don't have any control
over the way your body responds to
what's happening there
right because gravity and biology work
independently of your your choices
but on the psychological side if your
assumption is that you are an individual
that you are in control of your mind if
i start saying
harmful words to you i start insulting
you in various ways
well you have a choice right you can say
you know
he's saying that i'm a stupid idiot
right
and those are harmful words right that's
what those words mean and they are
intended as an
insult but i am not necessarily a
passive vehicle i don't
have to let that hurt me i can say he
thinks i'm a stupid idiot
well what does that really mean am i a
stupid idiot and i can think for myself
and form my own judgment i don't think
i'm stupid i don't think i'm an idiot
so really what your attempt to assault
insult me is going to fail
and i'm going to think oh he's just
attacking me right for some reason
so the point is my response to those
harmful words
is up to me and i'm in control of the
process
and that's what the individualist will
say so then they say sticks and stones
will
uh what it was sticks and stones will
break my bones but right words will
never hurt me because the words
uh and my response to them are up to me
as an individual agent but if you get
rid of individual agency then you start
to just say
words like any other thing i'm not in
control of them they shape me they
form me and if you are a being with some
power
then words are a form of violence on me
and i then become a victim
of your words do you want to spice up
your life
yeah well in that case i have just the
product for you it's screaming chimp
chili sauce made from fresh chilies
they're a british company based in
durham that create
beautiful chili sauces that are vegan
friendly
gluten-free and free of the 14 main
allergens
they're for [ __ ]
aside they have a whole range of flavors
all the way from mild
to wild for real men i'm a real man
they've got a range of unique and
classic flavors they've got pineapple
mango and papaya chimpotley excellent
punch
and original hot sauce go to
screamingchimp.com that's
screamingchimp.com
and spice up your winter and stephen
it's very interesting they're talking
about you know the the way that we
perceive
words but there are some words that have
very very real power and it's used again
in the authoritarian way in
in order to shut down arguments yes
you know and the way that these words
are used as tools for instance racist
bigger
transfer we all know what they are right
sure
yes well uh i agree with everything uh
they are used in the authoritarian way
but then uh
i is at least as a liberal individualist
will be able to recognize
that they are using those words in a
certain way so
and this is of course part of the
ongoing linguistic power struggle
because yes
words are a tool language is
functional and one of the things we try
to do
is not only understand the world using
language but try to communicate with
other people and
influence other people and if i'm an
authoritarian i will try to use
words uh in an authoritarian way and i
will try to use them as as weapons as
well
but i would reject it it's your you're
true that there are authority
you're correct rather there are
authoritarian people who use words like
fascist racist sexist and so on
in an authoritarian fashion to try to
shut down debate
and they they try to use them to get
inside your head
and to put you on the defensive right so
oh my god the guy called me a racist and
we know that's a big button pushing word
so i become jangled up emotionally
inside
and maybe and we know that people don't
function as well when they are
emotionally jangled up
and i don't know how to respond to this
i'm all confused and so
uh that puts the person who's using
those words in a
rhetorically advantageous purpose so
i would say i would agree with you that
yes rhetoric
in the post-modern linguistic framework
is
used as a weapon explicitly so
but i think what we then need to do is
just uh
not only engage in the the philosophical
debates about language and cognition and
so on
is to refuse to let them get away with
that particular
tactic so if you want to take racism
which does have a precise meaning
it is a real problem and broaden it into
this all-purpose weapon that you're
going to use on anyone
we have to fight back against that and
say that is a an illegitimate extension
of the word
racism and unfortunately at that point
we either have to have a discussion
about what the word properly should mean
or you just have to say this is not
someone i can have a meaningful
conversation with and just
walk away from the conversation see the
trouble there
is that we come back to this this point
that we came to earlier in the interview
which is
we are in a position of irresolvable
conflict and and so
the question the question that's been
worrying me
and us and many of our former guests
people like douglas murray something
that he feels strongly
what is the end game for this if we
can't reason ourselves out of this
position
because there is no reasonable rational
based
discussion how how does this get
resolved
yeah well uh if if if you can't reason
your way out of it then it does become a
power struggle
right and it become a matter of physical
force absolutely
uh you know if uh if
if you're dealing with a with an an
animal
that that wants to eat you you can't
reason your way out of it with the
animal then it does
become who's faster uh
who has the better physical weapons in
that in that confrontation
if it's uh to switch to human animal
context you are being
mugged in a dark alley and someone uh
uh is using physical threats against you
you're not going to be able to reason
your way out of it it's either then it
does come down to
can i physically overpower this person
or physically run away from this person
uh
and that's those are what the debates
are so then it does become a
philosophical issue in an institutional
context for the leadership of that
institution whether that is a principal
at a high school
or the dean at a university college or
the ceo at a at a business that person
has a responsibility to say
if we are going to do these uh run these
institutions on a broadly
liberal basis uh that this is going to
be a voluntary set of relationships that
we are entering into
and people have the right to have their
own ideas and to express
those ideas and we're going to have
civil debates we're going to
settle these things by reason if in the
midst of all of that we have people
who are fundamentally committed to
authoritarian physicalist
methods then we do need to remove those
people so if i'm a professor in my
classroom for example
i will let the debate between the
liberals and the authoritarians go to a
certain point and as long as it's a
debate
that's fine but if i have an
authoritarian in the student in my class
who wants to
physically intimidate non-authoritarian
students or threatens
violence with them or is talking
constantly and won't stop talking to
give other students a chance then i do
have to use my authority as professor in
the liberal sense to remove that student
from the classroom
because they are undermining the liberal
ethos of
that particular social institution i
would then say more broadly
at the level of deans and presidents of
universities they have to make a
decision
uh mi as the president of this
institution committed to a certain world
view a religious world view
or a utopian leftist world view and the
assumption is that all of the students
are and professors at this school
are here to discuss only that world view
that's fine
but if you are deciding as the president
of your institution
it's going to be a liberal education
institution then once students cross the
line and start becoming physical
themselves or professors cross the line
and start becoming physical themselves
they need to be removed
and and stephen you were in a formal
interview that we were watching you were
discussing about the terms left and
right
and how they have essentially become
meaningless i have somebody who's always
seen myself as being on the left
i used to be a school teacher for 12
years
viewers and listeners of the podcast who
are regular you can have a drink now
but kindly explain to people why is it
do you feel that these terms
in 2021 now really have
very little meaning ah well i think
they've
for a long time had very little meaning
uh because it was somewhat of an
arbitrary designation so
part of it is uh the the power of media
and media needs to have more simplistic
labels for the broad mass of people who
want information
uh packaged in certain ways in in
digestible chunks
so if we think and i'm going to speak
from the canadian and the
the american context we've got some very
big broad spread out
uh countries and the same thing of
course would apply apply in britain
with millions and millions of people and
the way political competition works out
is it typically gets winnowed down to a
few packages
now for me as a philosopher and anybody
who's an intellectual about these things
we're going to see these packages given
the complexity of society
are always going to have about 100
elements in them
and what you want to do is you want to
take each of those elements
and consider it on its own and look at
the arguments for and against and so
forth
and then very carefully pick and choose
what elements in those packages but if
you have 100 elements then
uh i don't know what the exponent would
be you could have all sorts of
combinations of
packages that that arise as a result of
thoughtful individuals working their way
through the packages and forming their
own sets of beliefs
but we do know that uh you know as with
cars as with
vcrs and i'm dating myself
but various kinds of electronic devices
things typically
devolve themselves into bundled packages
of things so it becomes apple versus
android it becomes vhs versus beta
it might become ford versus gm versus
chrysler or nissan versus right whatever
and these are big bundle things and the
same thing has happened in uh
in politics so what we end up with is
parties which are retailers
of of of political ideas
and the you know the intellectuals and
so forth for the host wholesalers
working out various
discrete elements but then they get
packaged by the retailers
and then sold to the to the broader
market and it's uh then
much easier to put together oh here's
our package of 100 ideas
here's our competing package of 100
ideas
uh but there's no necessity that it had
to be that package of 100 ideas versus
that package of 100 ideas
and then the media sells them or
or extends them out to the broader
public and the labels then
come to come to stick so uh one
encouraging thing though is
uh about the polarization and i think
polarization does have its social and
psychological costs but i think
it is a a cognitively healthy thing
because one of the things the
polarization does is rather than say
you know come come back to the american
context say instead of
you have to choose between being a
republican and being a democrat
and my entire lifetime everybody who's a
republican or a democrat or neither
is unsatisfied with all of the elements
in the in the package
what the polarization does is to push
things to an extreme
and then people think about the extremes
and then they think about what the
alternatives to the extremes are
and then they start to put different
packages together
and so then we start to say well let's
take the republicans and then we're
going to divide them into the religious
right
and then say that the free market right
and we'll do the same thing with the
left here's uh you know different
segments of the left
and that polarization then pushes things
in a breaking up fashion which i think
is
intellectually healthier it shows that
more people are thinking for themselves
instead of just
accepting i'm a leftist or i'm a
rightist these are adding all of these
adjectives
and so you have a better understanding
of what the political landscape is
and to the extent that that's happening
in the broader population i think that's
part of
improved political education
and and stephen when when is it so
again i'm on the left and it seems that
the left have gone this transformation
where they care more about identity and
identity groups
than they do about disparity in wealth
between rich and poor
why has that happened and how long has
this been happening for
well uh again a long story uh
part of the book that i think got me
invited to you guys my ex
explaining post-modernism uh skepticism
and socialism
from russo to foucault uh much of that
book is a history of the left right or
history of socialism over the course of
the last two centuries and it has gone
through
right multiple iterations and branchings
and splittings and mergers and
re-mergers and so on so it's all some
very
very complicated territories but yes on
this point
uh about exactly what you're saying this
shift from
caring about wealth inequality and gaps
there to identity groups that there's a
very important marker in the history of
left politics in the
1950s uh but especially in the 1960s
and and since then because for the first
century and a half or so
of modern left politics it was
primarily an economic differential issue
rich versus poor and we are
perhaps we hate the rich but we are
primarily supposed to be motivated by
concern for the poor and getting them
elevated
and the main criticism of capitalism or
whatever the alternative
is was that uh that it does not look
after
its poor members very well they fall
behind
rich get richer porgy and all that sort
of stuff but that argument
came to be seen as untenable by the time
you get to the 1950s and the 1960s of
course you still hear some leftists who
make that argument but it's very hard
in the modern world to argue that
capitalism
does not improve the material standards
for the vast majority of people
if you say i'm concerned for the workers
and then you go and you look at eighty
percent of the workers and the workers
have
two cars and air conditioning and big
screen tvs and they're going on
vacations
now they might not be going on vacations
like bill gates goes on vacations
but you can't say oh these impoverished
poor workers who are victims of
capitalism by the 50s and 60s that
argument wasn't flying very hard
and also the idea that if we have a
socialistic
system it's going to care about its
workers and elevate the workers uh by
the time we get to the middle part of
the 20th century there have been quite a
few experiments in socialism
and they had never done that they had
never done anything close to that
they had in fact impoverished so there
was a shift
then from primarily economic concerns to
another strategy
and the new strategy was that the
different groups in society again
it's there's a more collectivism that's
built into into
left politics uh uh
are are not being treated equally in
society
along other social dimensions aside from
economic dimensions so
maybe different racial groups or gender
groups or
or and then we shift to sexuality groups
or or maybe
other animal species we're not treating
them equally and we're driving them to
extinction and so on
so the economic arguments get put on the
back burner
on the left and other dimensions of
inequality
and group identities come to the to the
four
oh i was just going to say my final
point in this but
what we've seen now with the present
young generation
is a generation that are actually going
to do less well financially
than their forebears they're less likely
to own property they're they're not
going to
earn as much and so on and so on and so
forth don't
these arguments about inequality and
added to that the
ever widening gap between rich and poor
aren't these arguments now suddenly
becoming coming to the fore again
or shouldn't they be and aren't we wrong
to be focused on the identity stuff
when the when we do it like i said the
inequality between rich and poor is ever
more increasing
yeah all right well i'm a philosopher by
training but i do know
i think enough about economics to be to
be dangerous on this point but also i
know the history
uh and i'm so i'm going to make an
economic prediction here
the the next generation of young people
are going to be
richer than i am and they're going to be
richer than
you are now partly i'm going to make
that that's not very hard stephen
well okay maybe so you your generation
on average i'm sensing that you guys are
younger than i am um and partly this is
this is for historical reasons
i've read a lot of the history here and
francis the argument that you are making
that's exactly the argument that was
made in the 1990s
and it was made in the 1970s in the
1950s and the 1920s and the 1880s
that this generation's young people are
going to have a lower standard of living
than the previous generation in some
sense
the whatever we're doing has run its
course we are depriving them of
opportunities there's a wealth gap it's
it's uh it's an argument that gets
repeated over and over again
but i think it's driven by the same
fundamental assumptions about
opportunity and freedom and technology
and those are some very seductive
assumptions but they also are very deep
so we are pushed back to
what uh what intellectuals say about
economics what
uh uh what uh what intellectuals are
saying about those philosophical
assumptions so
if you want to say for example that you
are a representative young person
right now and you look at your
opportunities
for the future and you compare your
opportunities for the future now
with the previous generation young
people now have
more economic opportunities than
people did in the in the past
generations and
i think of course we have to start
looking at the data
but yes absolutely this is this is this
is the case
for example suppose i am a a creative
person in the visual fields and so on
and then 20 years ago i want to get into
making movies
are what are my options for getting into
movies 20 years ago well
i need to have about a quarter million
dollars worth of capital equipment in
order to be able to do so
right and then uh we fast forward one
generation
if you're a young person right now with
some creative movie making talents
what's your capital investment that you
need in order to be able to make
good movies maybe a few thousand dollars
so that then is to say
uh more younger people who are poorer
now
have more opportunity to be successful
in their fields
and that's just one example in in
computers there are more professions
that are being opened up
as a result of the new technologies that
are coming
they are it's not only that there are
more technologies making more
uh professions and more kinds of
creativity possible
uh they are also leveraging us in a way
that they make us more productive
and that's what wealth is becoming more
productive creating things that are more
valuable
to people on top of that they're also
becoming less expensive
so that uh more people more easily will
be able to
afford them now another example is you
know step outside of our our own
immediate context you know think about
you know the average person in uh in a
poorer part of
the world you know in i don't know peru
or
or or or you know nigeria right or
vietnam does that person have more
opportunities now for wealth creation
than
an equivalent peruvian uh nigerian
or vietnamese person a generation ago
and the data
are astounding about how much more
opportunity people have
stephen no argument on that point
whatsoever but let me interject the one
issue
in this country that that is animating a
lot of resentment
intergenerationally is the housing what
we call the housing crisis which is
it is ever more difficult for people in
this country young people particularly
to
get on the housing ladder and that means
their opportunity for accumulating
wealth
is significantly diminished versus
previous generations what do you say to
that
well i don't know very much about the
housing market in britain so it would be
uh
a bit difficult for me to to pronounce
on that
uh i can speak to the housing market in
toronto
my my hometown and of course they're
going to be
uh market pressures the the countries
that are
sexier in the world are going to attract
more people
the countries that are prosperous their
babies aren't going to die and they're
going to to live so their populations
are going to grow
you naturally then expect that there's
going to be increases on the on the
demand side so
london england toronto san francisco
these are sexy places lots of people
want to go there
so the question then is going to be on
the supply side
uh and my understanding in toronto is
that toronto
and san francisco it's pretty much the
same story uh
uh made it very difficult for new
development to happen yeah
yeah we have the same problem here yeah
so to the extent that you then say
uh we want to attract lots of people and
we have a rising population want them to
have housing
then if you at the same time are
preventing people from building housing
then you have a cognitive dissonance the
problem there is
then a political problem how the zoning
people
are thinking yeah act is the the fight
that has to be happening
fair point so let me say one more
one more thing a city like houston
which has had huge population growth but
housing is very affordable
in houston they've solved the political
problem in that actually by not having
that
that those oppressive set of zoning and
other kinds of restrictions as well so
i think it's a political problem i hear
you so in in summary what you're saying
is
that's not the housing pressures in this
country or elsewhere they're not a
reflection of
the capitalist system their reflection
of certain quirks of the political and
administrative state which i which i
accept completely
so let me come back francis previous
question because what we're really
trying to get out of you
is you know it's like with jokes when we
write a joke we may write a joke that we
think is funny but you go on stage and
you try it out and it sometimes it lands
and sometimes
that joke doesn't but another one does
right so why have these
ideas this postmodernist world view why
is it landing so
damn hard right now what is the reason
that people
look to it and embrace it with such
vigor yeah
well i think it's because human beings
are a smart species
and the the uh the philosophical
framework
that they adopt when they are young is
decisive
you know we all go through the
soul-searching uh
teen years particularly if we're
reflective what kind of person am i
going to be
what do i want my my life and then we
make a commitment to a certain set of
values so
what we learn from our parents from our
teachers and then particularly
if we are very thoughtful about these
things and we go to educate our to
into higher education that becomes
decisive
people live what they believe
and so then it comes back to the uh
the arguments that have been developed
and have prevailed in
universities over the course of the last
two generations
what happened in the 60s and 70s was an
anti-modernist
philosophical framework we call it
post-modernism
came to positions of significance and
dominance in the humanities
and that's very important because what
is it to be a human being that's what
the humanities are all about
and we go to literature we try to learn
from history we take
courses in anthropology and political
science so
the philosophy that prevailed in the 60s
70s and 80s was decisive
and universities are very important here
because that's where the next generation
of teachers
goes for their training so they take
those humanities courses
and then they go off and they become
teachers to millions and millions of
students in the next generation
that's the philosophy they teach
journalists go to university
and they get their training that's what
they teach and then that shapes their
journalistic approach
lawyers go to university and then they
go off into the legal profession and
they
try to influence and change the laws and
so on and of course most politicians
come from
a background of being lawyers or some
sort of university education as well
so the political landscape changes so
what we are seeing is
high theory that was developed in the
60s and 70s
in universities by some very smart
individuals that prevailed
that then taught a next generation of
intelligent people in the professions
and then it has spilled out into the
culture as a result of that broad
cultural education
and stephen do you think and this is
where i'm going to more and more mind
thinking do you think that these big
institutions
whether it's a university whether it's
the justice system whether it's the
education system
whatever it may be they should be
utterly apolitical
it is not their job to push their own
political views and opinions
on the minds of the employees or the
people who work there are the people who
go there to study
uh apolitical in the sense that i think
there should be a separation of
education
and politics so you know that's
why we have the institution of tenure
and academic freedom for example that
the people we think
are dealing with uh the controversial
ideals need to be
insulated from political pressures right
so in that sense says absolutely
and i think this uh this is the harder
argument but it does mean separation
from educational funding from
politicians because
politicians have a terrible track record
of he who pays the piper calls the tune
now to the extent that the liberal
education ethos has been strong
and the idea of academic freedom for
fearless
truth seekers to be able to speak
anything they want
has been strong we've been able to marry
some level of political funding with
academic freedom
but we're entering into dangerous
territory to the extent that the liberal
education thing is gone
but then if we ask apolitical in the
sense that the people who are
inside the institutions like deans and
professors and so forth should they be
apolitical
or should the ceos of corporations and
managers should they be apolitical as
well
and here i would say no i don't think so
uh
i think education should be about
everything
including political education so an
important part of life
is politics and we need to be able to
prepare young people to enter into
political life
but if i'm committed to some sort of
liberal democracy then what that means
is i have to ask
what's going to enable my students to
become
good participants in a liberal
democratic process and for me that means
they need to be able to learn how to
think how to think about very difficult
issues
and about controversial issues and so
part of my responsibility then is to
train them on all of those cognitive
skills and
the emotional skills because all of
these things push our emotional buttons
and we get angry and frustrated
so emotional education about developing
a thicker skin
and the tolerance requirements and so
forth all of those are feeders into
politics and then in terms of my
discipline i'm a philosopher so i only
bump up against politics occasionally
but if if my job is to teach british
government or or comparative political
systems then of course
that's a legitimate academic field and
it should be taught but should be taught
in a liberal education fashion so be
political absolutely
as for ceos i do think they they need to
be political
and part of the problem is that many
ceos have not had political education
you know in our text society a lot of
them were
engineers and they just uh you know were
fascinated with their
with their the things that they're able
to develop and they didn't think about
very much but then suddenly they're in
charge of a
50 million dollar company and they're
dealing with people with all of these
ethnicities and they are entering into a
global economy
they don't know anything about politics
so they typically then will fall back on
just grabbing an off-the-shelf politics
that they've not really thought through
very much and that leads to
problems so i do think ceos
they are going to be political animals
your your businesses
are social and they are political and
also you are dealing
particularly in the modern world with uh
with the with your own government so you
need to know how that works and you're
dealing with international government so
uh it should not be a politicized
education but it should be political
education
it's got to be in there yeah that's so
that's a very good point um
stephen before we ask you our final
question uh let me ask you this
when you did your interview with our
mutual friend john anderson when you
were in australia
you finished that interview uh by
talking about how optimistic you are
about the
the the outcomes of some of the things
that we've been talking about
uh and i imagine you would have recorded
it somewhere between 12 and
18 months ago um are you still
optimistic now
well yeah i am overall optimistic
uh i think uh in the near term the next
five years
are going to be pretty ugly uh
because because uh yeah
you know this is a statement
it is a philosophical battle and those
ones move slowly but it has become a
cultural battle
and cultural battles always become
politics but politics is
in the final analysis about police guns
military and so forth and that's that
that's the ugly part
and we do have a generation of younger
people who have not been trained
in good cognitive skills and good civil
discussion skills so
it will be ugly uh ugly in that sense
now why i'm optimistic is uh
i do think there are certain human
constants i mean we are a smart species
and one of the things that has happened
is uh that
this upsurge of irrationality and
incivility has taken most people by
surprise
and most people though are decent civil
rational beings
and once they get up the learning curve
about what they're dealing with they
will enter into the debate
and there will be a retraining of
civility and rationality from the broad
massive people
i'm also optimistic because uh you know
in in institutions of higher education
there's a huge number of smart smart
people
all over the world and mostly they they
uh
as academics they like to be siloed they
like to just focus on their own thing
but
increasingly over the last 10 years they
are looking around
realizing that something is rotten in
the state of denmark
and they are starting to re-enter into
the debate
inside their own institutions and to
clean house so i do think there's
a case to be made for self-reform within
the institutions of higher education
there is a political element we do have
a significant amount of state funding of
education
however jaded and cynical we are about
our politicians
they do recognize that they have a
responsibility
to make sure that those education
dollars are actually spent on
education and not on politicization
and so they get pressure from their
constituents and they do
then put pressure on presidents and
chancellors and so on to
clean house inside and i think that
cleaning house will go
in the direction of a reinvigoration of
liberal education
but i think i'm most optimistic because
uh
young people young people can be subject
to
indoctrination in education but most
people recognize even as young people
when they are being
indoctrinated and they just start to
tune out the indoctrinators
and they have all kinds of sources of
information and values
available to them now that people did
not
so the indoctrinators will have limited
effect increasingly and also young
people
i think it's built into human nature
that we we grow up we want to make
something of our lives we want something
real we want something genuine uh we
want
love we want our careers to be
meaningful so any sort of
world view that is very jaded
and cynical and adversarial and says
everything is
[ __ ] and just attack and hate uh
that's only going to be attractive to a
subset of the
the younger population most young people
will gravitate naturally to the
healthier disciplines
the healthier teachers and professors
and go on and make something
of their lives i think that's a human
natural
well thank you very very much for that
stephen it was an absolutely
brilliant interview uh appreciate that
thank you by the way oh thank you
we have one final question that we
always end all our interviews with
and that is what is a one thing we're
not talking about as a society
but we really should be yeah well i just
completed a manuscript called
eight philosophies of education with uh
my co-authors a
younger canadian philosopher of
education andrew colgan
where we look at the uh the the many
different philosophies
that have been operationalized in
education and all of them are there so
uh we we have a kind of chaotic
education system right now
uh with a mixture of all sorts of
elements and nobody is nobody is happy
with
but i think the thing that we are not
thinking about the most
is there's a disjunct between
our idealism about young people so all
of us when we become
parents or we become teachers we are
we're idealistic
about here's this baby and all of the
possibilities for this child and we're
just
excited and jazzed for it and we want
this person to have the best possible
life and then if we think about you know
before we send the child to school
how we educate this person we give this
this kid lots of opportunities and toys
and we're encouraging and the kid can
explore and experiment and the kid
basically plays
for five years and all of that is
beautiful and wonderful
and then what do we do we send kids to
school
if we just pause for a moment and just
form an image in our heads what does
school
mean i bet 99 of people are going to say
rows of desks kids sitting at the desk
listening to the teacher writing it down
or reading from the textbook and
everybody is reading the same pages
and working on the same problem and the
assumption is that the answers are
already known
and you have to just memorize this uh
and you better not fail the test
or uh and if you want to go to the
bathroom you have to ask
permission to get up and move around so
we have this very
regimented uh authoritarian
one-size-fits-all school system that we
have developed
and we put our kids in there for 12
years
and what is 12 years of that kind of
schooling
going to do to those young people now
most of us i think also went through
schooling systems like that and we know
how boring and how vaguely dehumanizing
it is so to my way of thinking the one
thing that we should be thinking a lot
more is
why is there such a disjunct between how
we
raise kids for the first five years of
their lives to what we then do to them
for 12 years
and then of course we we say you know
once you're out of the education system
you're free
you can do anything you want dream big
solve problem be an innovator be a
creative person and so forth
but that 12 years of education has
the opposite of all of that now we are
smart we know the history we know about
steve jobs and albert einstein
and all of the great musical performance
and somehow lots and lots of people
survive and creep their keep their
creativity and their humanity
intact despite the school system but to
some extent we are still
highly tolerant of this kind of school
system
we need to do better and we know that we
can do better so what we're not thinking
about is
how seriously to experiment
with different kinds of schooling uh
we all know it's important but we're
complacent uh so that's what we need to
be directing our energies to
stephen that is a suitably fascinating
end to what has been an absolutely
brilliant interview
we really thank you uh we wish you all
the very best with the manuscript
and uh hopefully when all of this stuff
is over next time you're in london we'd
love to have you here on the set
and have a proper chat face to face
great in you guys
yeah brilliant questions yeah absolutely
timely topic and uh
i will see you in london at some point
we really look forward to and if you've
been watching make sure you check out
stephen's work
and we will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or an interview take care
and they all go out at 7pm uk time
whether it's an episode or a live stream
see you soon guys